"THE FIVE."
♪
>> Greg: IMAGINE YOU ARE
HOME FOR THANKSGIVING AND
YOUR SON BRINGS HOME A BUDDY
FROM THE DORMS FOR DINNER.
HIS FRIEND IS REAL
EXCITABLE, TELLING YOU ABOUT
A CLASS HE TOOK ON AMERICAN
IMPERIALISM THAT TOTALLY
BLEW HIS MIND.
HE IS SO UP.
YOU WONDER IF HE GOT INTO
YOUR MEDICINE CABINET.
>> THERE IS GOING TO BE
MASSIVE MIGRATIONS OF TENS
OF HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE FROM COMPANIES
UNHABITABLE OR UNDER WATER
THAT ARE ABOVE THE SEA RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS OUR FINAL CHANCE THE
SCIENTISTS ARE ABSOLUTELY
UNANIMOUS ON THIS THAT WE
HAVE NO MORE THAN 12 YEARS
TO TAKE INCREDIBLY BOLD
ACTION ON THIS CRISIS.
>> Greg: LIKE A 6-YEAR-OLD
WHO JUST SNORTED A LINE OF
POP ROCKS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT MUCH
HAND MOVEMENT WITH ALL THAT
JAZZ.
WITH ALL THAT GESTURING WHO
DOES HE REMIND YOU OF?
>> EVEN THE PRESIDENT
NOTICED.
>> I THINK HE HAS A LOT OF
HAND MOVEMENT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN SO MUCH
I SAID IS HE CRAZY OR IS
THAT JUST THE WAY HE ACTS?
SO, I HAVE NEVER SEEN HAND
MOVEMENT.
I WATCHED HIM A LITTLE WHILE
THIS MORNING DOING, I ASSUME
IT WAS SOME KIND OF A NEWS
CONFERENCE.
AND I HAVE ACTUALLY NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING QUITE LIKE IT.
STUDY IT.
I'M SURE YOU WILL AGREE.
>> Greg: STUDY IT.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO HAND IT
TO HIM.
HE SAYS WHAT YOU ARE
THINKING.
I DO FEEL A NICKNAME COMING.
BETO ANNOUNCED IS HE
RUNNING.
THIS COINCIDING WITH A
DROOLING VANITY FAIR COVER
STORY WRITTEN BY THE SAME
SUCKLE BUCKET WHO FELL FOR
JOHN EDWARDS.
THE WRITER IS SO SMITTEN HE
CAN'T SEE STRAIGHT.
IT ISN'T JUST PURPLE IT'S
PUTIN WHAT
PETIN WHAT
PEUSN WHAT
PEUSS.WHAT
PEUSS.THAT
PEUSS.THET
PEUSS.THE MEDIA'S BIG NARRATIVE
BETO IS DAVID TO TRUMP'S
GOLIATH.
BUT ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN
ALIVE FOR MORE THAT TWO
SEASONS OF "60 MINUTES"
KNOWS THE GIANT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN THE MEDIA AND DAVID HAS
BEEN ANYONE WHO DOESN'T FALL
IN LINE.
FOX NEWS HAS BEEN DAVID FOR
20 YEARS.
SO YOU CAN'T SAY THAT BETO
IS DAVID WHEN HE HAS A FULL
FORCE OF THE GOLIATH BEHIND
HIM AND YOU CAN'T BLAME BETO
EITHER.
IT'S NOT HIS FAULT VANITY
FAIR HAS MADE HIM THEIR MAN
CRUSH.
BETO IS A YOUNG WHITE MALE
EMBRACED BY A LEFT WING RAG
WHO IS HOPING TO SELL
PERFUME ADS TO COVER THE
STENCH.
HE CLAIMS HE WAS JUST BORN
TO DO.
THIS HOW IS THAT FOR WHITE
PRIVILEGE?
ALL RIGHT, JUAN, I THINK
THAT'S RACIST FOR WHAT HE
SAID.
I WANTED TO BEAT YOU TO THE
PUNCH.
HE SAID HE IS BORN.
IS THAT BECAUSE IS HE A
WHITE MALE?
HAVE YOU GOT TO BE UPSET
THAT HE IS GETTING ALL THIS
ATTENTION, RIGHT?
>> Juan: NO.
WHY?
TELL ME WHY YOU THINK THAT?
>> Greg: THERE IS ALL THESE
OTHER CREDIBLE CANDIDATES
OUT THERE.
KAMALA DIDN'T GET THIS
ROLLOUT.
>> Juan: I THINK KAMALA GETS
A LOT OF ATTENTION.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> KAMALA I SHOULD SAY.
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT E
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT C
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT T
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT M
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT N
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT T
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT A
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT O
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT N
IN FACT RECOLLECT THE, IN FACT D
HIM IS LIKE OBAMA'S FIRST
CAMPAIGN.
PEOPLE SEE HIM AS EXCITING
NEW HOPE AND CHANGE
CANDIDATE AT A TIME WHEN THE
COUNTRY IS POLARIZED AND WE
WANT TO CHOKE EACH OTHER.
THEY SAY HEY BRING THIS GUY
ON.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT HANDS.
WHY DID HE DO THAT?
>> Greg: EVERYBODY SAW IT.
>> Juan: YOU HAD A
LEGITIMATE POINT BUT TRUMP,
GIVEN WHAT -- GIVEN WHAT
PEOPLE SAID ABOUT HIS HANDS,
I JUST THINK HE SHOULD HAVE
STAYED AWAY FROM THE TOPIC.
>> Greg: GOING TO BE ABOUT
HANDS FROM HERE ON IN,
KENNEDY.
>> Kennedy: I LOOK AT ALL
THE CANDIDATES AND EVEN THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES FROM
2016 AND WITH EACH OF THEM
THEY INHABIT A CERTAIN
SPACE.
AND EVEN IF YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH THEM, YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE APPEAL IS AND I
UNDERSTAND THE APPEAL OF
BERNIE.
I HAVE ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD THE
BERNIE APPEAL.
I AGREE WITH HIM ON ALMOST
NOTHING.
MAYBE THE SURVEILLANCE STATE
AND POSSIBLY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
NOT ONLY DO I NOT UNDERSTAND
THE APPEAL OF BETO O'ROURKE,
AS AN INDEPENDENT VOTER, I
AM SO WILLING TO HEAR
ANYONE'S PITCH ON HOW YOU
CAN MAKE MY LIFE BETTER.
I'M ALL FOR IT HE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFICS AT ALL.
AND LIZ WARREN EVEN THOUGH
SHE HAS GOD-AWFUL IDEAS AT
LEAST SHE IS BRAVE ENOUGH TO
PUT POLICY POSITIONS OUT
THERE SO PEOPLE CAN PICK
THEM APART.
HE GIVES US NOTHING.
HE GIVES US THESE BLANKET
PHRASES THAT ARE DRIPPING
WITH BETO SWEETNESS THAT
DELIVER NOTHING.
OH WE ARE AT CROSSROADS AND
THIS IS A CRISIS AND I'M
BORN TO DO.
THIS TO DO WHAT?
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
PROPOSING?
>> Lisa: TO TALK WITH HIS
HANDS.
HE WOULD BE A GREAT MARION A MAR
HE WOULD BE A GREAT MARION A MAO
HE WOULD BE A GREAT MARION A MAN
HE WOULD BE A GREAT MARION A MA-
>> Juan: I LIKE THE OPTIMISM
AS I SAID.
HE SAYS YES TO THE CLIMATE
CHANGE DEAL.
>> Kennedy: ANTHONY ROBIN
SHOULD BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT
OF OPTIMISM IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANT.
>> Juan: IS HE ALL FOR
ABORTION.
IS HE ALL FOR GOVERNMENT.
>> Kennedy: IS HE ALL FOR
ABORTION?
THAT'S NOT GOOD.
HORRIBLE.
BABY KILLER?
>> Juan: NOT FAIR TO SAY HE
HAS NO POSITION.
>> Lisa: EVEN IF YOU LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE HE SAYS HE
SUPPORTS THE CLIMATE CHANGE,
THE GREEN NEW DEAL GREEN
DEAL, RIGHT YOU?
LOOK AT THE FACT DURING THE
2018 ELECTION.
HE RECEIVED MORE MONEY FROM
THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY
THAN ANY OTHER CANDIDATE
BESIDES SENATOR DEAD TUZ.
EXPORTING NATURAL GAS TO
OTHER COUNTRIES WHICH RUNS
CONTRADICTORY FOR WHAT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL WANTS AND
STAND FOR.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU DON'T
HEAR MUCH ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
HE WAS PROTECTED AND
INSULATED FROM THE MEDIA AND
THE LEFT BECAUSE HE RAN
AGAINST TED CRUZ WHICH THE
BULK OF THE MEDIA AND THE
LEFT DESPISE NUMBER ONE
ENEMY BESIDES PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> PART OF THAT PROTECTION
AND ATTENTION LED TO MASS
AMOUNTS OF MONEY THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO RAISE.
80-SOMETHING MILLION DOLLARS
MORE THAN ANY OTHER
CANDIDATE.
EVIDENCE WILL NOT HAVE THAT
IN A CROWDED PRIMARY FIELD.
HE WENT BE THE ONLY PERSON
ON THE LEFT RECIPIENT OF THE
MEDIA'S ADORATION AS WE HAVE
SEEN WITH PEOPLE LIKE KAMALA
HARRIS AS WELL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE STANDS
OUT IN A CROWD OF PRIMARY
FIELD.
WHAT DISTINGUISHES HIM
BESIDES THE FACT HE CAN
SKATEBOARD?
>> Kennedy: IS HE A KOOK.
HE CLAIMS TO HAVES MASTERED
A BOARD SPORT DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT HE IS DOING NO APTITUDE
KOOK.
>> Greg: IS HE MORE BETO
O'ROURKE THAN BETO O'ROURKE
IS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT OF
NICKNAMES YET.
>> Jesse: FOR BETO?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Jesse: YOU HAD A GOOD ONE
THE OTHER DAY.
>> Greg: MAESTRO BECAUSE IS
HE LIKE A CONDUCTOR MAESTRO
BETO?
>> Jesse: I WAS WANTING YOU
TO REPEAT THE OTHER ONE AND
GET IN TROUBLE FOR.
HE DOES LOOK LIKE A SIGN
LANGUAGE WAGE INTERPRETER
PRESS CONFERENCE WARNING
ABOUT IMPENDING BLIZZARD.
YOU KNOW THOSE CRAZY PEOPLE?
IT'S MESMERIZING AND CAN'T
STOP LOOK AT IT IN A STRANGE
WAY LIKEABLE.
HE MARRIED AN HEIRESS
SHARING PROBLEM.
PLATITUDES LIKE EMPTY
VESSEL.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU
UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE LIKE
HIM BECAUSE HE IS YOUNG.
HE CAN RAISE A LOT OF MONEY.
HE HAS CHARISMA WITH THE
KIDS.
NOW, THE MEDIA LIKES HIM
BECAUSE THE MEDIA WANTS TO
BE HIM.
YOU THINK ABOUT HIS PROFILE.
HE WENT TO COLUMBIA.
HE LIKES COFFEE SHOP.
>> Kennedy: PRIVILEGED.
>> Jesse: MORE COMFORTABLE.
>> Kennedy: YOU WERE MIDDLE
CLASS.
>> Jesse: HAS A PODCAST.
OBVIOUSLY A HUGE POETRY GUY.
THAT'S SOMETHING THEY ASPIRE
TO.
AND THEN WHEN THEY WRITE
ABOUT HIM, THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: HE IS THE MEDIA.
>> Jesse: WHEN THEY WRITE
ABOUT HIM THIS IS HOW THEY
WRITE.
THE TEXAS WIND HIS HIS HAIR
AS HE LEANED IN TO THE FOOD
TRUCK AND ORDERED A BURRITO
TO GIVE TO THE HOMELESS
VETERAN PLAYING A BROKEN
GUITAR.
IT'S LIKE THEY
SENSATIONALIZE THE MOST
TRIVIAL THINGS ABOUT HIM
LIKE IS HE JESUS.
>> Greg: I WANT TO GET TO
CHRIS MATTHEWS WHO
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, HE IS
NO CONSERVATIVE SAYING
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME THING
THAT YOU ARE SAYING ABOUT
THE RECENT VANITY FAIR.
>> BY THE WAY, BRING BACK
THAT COVER OF -- THAT COVER
IS THE BEST KISS I HAVE SEEN
FOR A CANDIDATE FOR A LONG
TIME.
I ALWAYS SAY THE CANDIDATE
WINS WHO HAS THE SUN IN HIS
FACE WHO LOOKS LIKE SUNNY
OPTIMISTIC, NOT THE INDOOR
BUREAUCRAT SITTING AT SOME
DESK.
THAT'S THE IMAGE YOU WANT.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT THE SUN IN
HIS FACE IT'S THE MEDIA
KISSING HIS BUTT.
IT'S NOT THE SUN.
>> Juan: HE IS THE OUTSIDER.
>> Lisa: HOW?
>> Juan: IN THE TRUMPIAN
STYLE.
>> Lisa: LET ME GIVE KENNEDY
A COMPLIMENT.
YOU SAID HE HICK NAME SHOULD
BE BETA OWE
BE BETA O DORK.
HE COMES ACROSS AS WEAK AND
IF HE RUNS IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHO PROJECTS STRENGTH
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING
TO WORK FOR BETA.
>> Juan: HOW'S COME HE GOT
SO MUCH REACTION FROM THE
PRESIDENT?
>> Lisa: BECAUSE OF PEOPLE
LIKE YOU, JUAN.
>> Greg: CANNOT DENY THE
HAND MOVEMENT.
INFLATABLE MAN COMPARISON.
THAT'S PERFECT.
IT'S EITHER LIKE HE IS LIKE
A CROSS BETWEEN THE
INFLATABLE MAN AND SLENDER
MAN AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT
IS.
>> Kennedy: NOT THE
TRANSFORMATIONAL FIGURE THAT
BARACK OBAMA WAS.
I'M SORRY.
>> Lisa: BARACK OBAMA DIDN'T
HAVE A SUPER CROWDED PRIMARY
FIELD EITHER.
>> Kennedy: ALL HE D. HAD TO
DO WAS ELBOW HILLARY OUT OF
THE WAY.
>> Jesse: BIG DISSERVICE TO
BARACK OBAMA TO COMPARE BETO
TO HIM.